[Music]
[Music]
the structure has polymorphic right we
had to attach each neuron non non
sequential why didn't you just reprogram
the synapses to work collectively
because we didn't think of it I'm sure
you did your best
ready run from it
the end is near we're gonna need some
help
how you been buck not bad for the end of
the world
[Music]
Darrin don't fight a while
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war you said we were
going to open what conduct to the rest
of the world this is not what I imagined
or give you imagine the Olympics maybe
even a Starbucks everywhere April 27
here we on the set of Avengers I've been
lucky enough along with other guardians
of the galaxy to join up with the
Avengers and be here and get an
opportunity to save the world does it
make you an Avenger now as well I don't
know maybe like a third-string Avenger
yeah was one of the founding members
yeah thank you you know out of all the
people that I've had the good fortune to
work with these two particular guys and
the triumvirate that we formed together
it's very special friendship and
decade-plus of time together go team
it's been this witnessing of like
people's lives growing and changing it's
been a really cool experience working
with Lizzy is been really really awesome
and I think there is something very
powerful about being able to play women
who do heroic things and those women are
so awesome so we've had a really good
time hanging out with everyone on the
set is one of the best parts of this job
actually because it does have this kind
of large extended family feel I had a
bit of a bucket of someone's worth
practice I thought he'd be good fun I'm
proven completely wrong in that front he
was arduous and boring and not
particularly funny
well at first Blanche it's hard to know
what to make a Cumberbatch and then the
more time I spent with him on and off
set I just kind of infatuated with this
guy I was thinking you know the journey
that Robert Downey jr. is made he's the
Godfather of all this is literally been
the adventure of a lifetime
I get a little misty thinking about it
so you know I lucked out
[Music]
you
you